[Musique]
ça a du bon ça à du mauvais ma c'est une
façon sympathique d'approché avec un
autre ça non pas être mal quand on est
jeune si la naïve bien bon ben c'est
agréable de draguer disons
notre hôte je suis contre dans la mesure
où les femmes ne peuvent pas en faire
autant
ah je suis pour je trouve que c'est
sympathique c'est chouette de se faire
traquer ben ouais je crois pas en salade
rails pour moi c'est des conneries
la drague c'est une chose naturelle moi
je lis des sous ça je trouve que je
trouve que c'est totalement pourri
moi je veux dire
pour moi la drague
c'est quelque chose
d'abord de totalement fait la pratique
et je trouve ça absolument degers
jalouse je peux vous dire que d'abord
comme mac os et dans la rue comme ça
avec une caméra à tous j'ai l'impression
que c'est bon de draguer alors que
peut-être que je serai un mec je ne
dirais pas la même chose c'est un sport
un sport de frimeur d'abord parce que la
drague c'est essentiellement de la frime
en fait ça marche pas ça marche
tellement ya pas de dry a pas de
technique moi j'y crois pas en sa traîne
rag c'est merveilleux la drague
quand on drague on drague quelqu'un qui
auparavant vous êtes déjà dragué soit
par les yeux soit par son allure soit
par enfin quelque chose qui vous fait
savoir que c'est possible et vous est ce
que vous draguez moi bien sûr je fais
que ça depuis 25 ans il m'arrive oui
souvent voiture qu'on joue un beau
garçon je regarde je drague pas comme ça
enfin c'est qu'il est normal que les
femmes bragg aussi c'est des sept
merveilles du monde la drague chaque
femme est un univers différent c'est un
parfum c'est un bouquet de fleurs c'est
chouette d'avoir des fleurs chez soi non
l'action lorsqu'on voudra y réagissent
pas trop mal et réactions le défaut à
chapet des fois ça plaît pas enfin ils
sont contents ça dépend si on est bien
coiffé pas comme aujourd'hui par exemple
enfin si on est là bien sûr les bien
bronzé on arrive vacances et tout ça va
ça dépend on peut tomber sur des sales
caractères des caractères sympa mais en
général c'est toujours joyeux se finit
11ème qui restaurent dans un petit
bistrot
quel est votre but
[Musique]
prague et pour avoir une compagnie où
viendra gay pour sortir une fille de mon
but c'est trouver le l'oiseau rare c'est
surtout la communication
évidemment où tous les hommes veulent en
venir vient certainement de sortir avec
une fille
et puis éventuellement d'aller plus loin
ah je me pose pas de questions je vois
quelque chose de beau jeudi à il est
mignon et j'ai pas le temps parce que je
suis toujours en train de courir mais je
me dis bon ben on va quand disons que je
sais ce que vous faites bayer dans un
même
ça vous plairait pas de temps en temps
que les frais soient pas désagréable oui
beaucoup par les hommes ne croient pas
que les garçons noah de plus les filles
que les garçons
généralement quand on parle de drax et
les hommes qui draguent les fans oui si
ça reste très très sérieux aux fins
assez lointain maison je n'apprécierais
pas tellement mais je crois que de toute
façon on ne choisit jamais aux femmes
[Musique]